this is a very funny movie and a great
idea for a movie you've got all these
funny people in it but you're all
playing yourselves heightened versions
of ourselves yes not exact versions of
yourselves but but but still seth
rogen's playing seth rogen james
franco's playing james franco you're
playing craig robinson and it's the end
of the world you're having a party and
you're all high
yes yes not unlike some of the parties
that we go to but uh
seth
and evan they came up with this idea and
they you know said you guys want to be a
part of this and we absolutely did now i
was a heightened version of myself part
of me is
you know me like i do the a song in a
movie that i always kind of do with my
acting and stuff like that but uh then
the parts that you know you dance in
between the real and the heightened like
there's a part where i admit to murder
and that's not me
the part where you murder is not you
that's not that's good to know uh i did
mention uh there's a lot of uh
drug usage in the movie were you guys
really high in these scenes or were you
acting no no no no no they have this
movie marijuana i don't know what the
name of it is but did uh you know you
smoked that on the set and that's it
just looks really like marijuana now
the trailer is a different story that's
not part of set so there's something
different happens when you go trailer
[Laughter]
because you're playing heightened
versions of yourself like like uh
michael sarah who's such a sweet guy
is playing the biggest a-hole of all
time in this movie he's playing a
coked-out sex drug addicted
sexual deviant yeah yeah so we're seeing
the real hamburgers
now you work with uh james franco in
this movie and a lot of people james
franco's been on the show a lot of i
interviewed many people that have worked
with him and they all say he's hard to
get to know you don't know if you've met
the real james franco right i almost
feel like i work with a hologram he's
he's
he's a mystery this dude he's you know
and you know yeah you don't feel like
you know him that well but he disarms
you from getting to know him because he
throws that little you know a little
look he kind of
you know he kind of dips his head and
looks at you dips his head squints his
eyes yeah i think we have a picture of
that i think we yeah there he is
he's right there he kind of looks at you
he does that
now how was uh seth rogen is the
director how is seth rogen as a director
seth and evan
rogan evan goldberg they're great it was
like being in the basement with your
friends and somebody pulls out the
cameras hey let's shoot let's make a
movie and it was just that much fun and
that collaborative
but um i mean i will say this there was
a
i want to call it a power trip but there
was some
something going on there like they made
it with both of them yeah they
one of these it was one of those days
where they were like we don't have time
come on uh shoot just craig put this on
and they gave me a blind wig and some
red lipstick and
and then it turns out we were doing the
drug sequence we were
doing spiderman
and franco was um the green goblin and
he was on a skateboard and stuff was
pushing him around that's supposed to be
the hoverboard right yeah and then danny
was spiderman he's gonna put you and
they made me
they made me marry jane
i'm serious yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
i wasn't happy about it no you don't
seem happy about it
you're very upset